euh faut-il avoir peur du tout nouveau
virus ressemblant au covid découvert en
Russie alors ça c'est le Costa 2 ça
n'est pas une croisière c'est un virus
il a découvert il a été découvert sur
des chauves-souris en Russie par une
équipe de chasseurs chercheurs le
problème de Costa c'est qu'il est
capable d'infecter les humains entre les
rats entre Costa entre non mais
franchement entre Gilles Verdez on est
pas bien il échappe aux anticorps et au
vaccin du covid-19 ça veut dire donc en
fait on va faire tous les vaccins et on
va devoir rajouter un autre vaccin pour
le Costa 2 si ça continue ils ont pas
trouvé encore
sur deux tu te fais
vaccinera non fais-le ici parce que hier
j'ai eu un pas fais-le là maintenant là
j'ai le vaccin j'ai la sixième dose
on va devenir des couscoussières non
mais attendez non mais c'est pas
possible alors encore infecté personne
fait déjà beaucoup parler de lui
petit récap va-t-on vivre un nouveau
virus et on aura avec nous l'excellent
Enrique Casalino
infectiologue et chef des urgences à
l'hôpital Bichat ouais beaucoup Enrique
casano je sais que tu as un petit coup
de cœur pour lui il va venir ce qu'il a
un petit accent comme ça à l'accent il
s'exprime très bien il est sexy j'aime
bien ces idées aussi en plus ah ouais et
on est très amis enfin communique
beaucoup ah ouais mais il te connaît pas
mais si il me connait si stéthoscope
alors compenser tout juste en avoir fini
avec le covid comme l'a annoncé le
président américain la pandémie est
terminée les scientifiques suivent
aujourd'hui de près l'apparition d'un
tout nouveau virus proche du covid du
virus Costa 2
identifier chez les chauves-souris Costa
2 pourraient se transmettre à l'homme et
un quête donc de plus en plus et
effectivement c'est pas très rassurant
on parle même d'une menace mondiale ce
nouveau virus pourrait même échapper au
vaccin actuel des vaccins qui existent
aujourd'hui contre le covid y compris
qu'aux micro-onde ne sont pas efficaces
faut-il avoir peur du tout nouveau virus
ressemblant au covid découvert en Russie
le professeur Enrique Casalino est avec
nous ce soir dans TPMP alors Enrique
juste avant qu'on parle du Costa 2 juste
l'irra
sur non parce que il paraît qu'il y a de
plus en plus de leptospirose
c'est de plus en plus c'est une maladie
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer cette
maladie c'est important pour une urine
alors la lectospirose est une maladie
qui donne quelque chose qui ressemble à
une hépatite très grave pour mourir ça
peut bien sûr on peut même en mourir
donc on est surtout exposé lorsqu'on va
par exemple dans de l'eau dans des des
cours d'eau où il y a eu il y a des rats
et donc l'érable pisse cette bactérie
c'est une leptospire et du coup on peut
se contaminer alors que on n'a pas été
mordu on n'a pas fonctionné on l'a même
pas vu
c'est quoi cette histoire Clément je
crois les entrepôts en fait les canettes
sont comme ça c'est pour ça que
maintenant on met des caches
le Conseil généralement est de ne jamais
boire directement d'une canette c'est ce
que je fais moi tout le temps et l'autre
élément qui est un conseil important
c'est que si vous êtes mordu
accidentellement par un rat il faut
savoir qu'il faut quand même aller
consulter parce que il peut y avoir une
bactérie qui est dans la gueule des rats
qui peut donner des infections
particulières et qui nécessitent dans
certains cas rien que parce que la
morsure est celle d'un rat des
antibiotiques d'emblée on peut se
transformer en a pas du tout
il semblerait qu'ils ont une vie
sexuelle très intéressante
avec l'excellent professeur Casalino
faut-il avoir peur du tout nouveau virus
ressemblant covid découvert en Russie
c'est incroyable maintenant parle de
tout nouveau virus on dirait que c'est
le nouvel iPhone
alors le Costa 2 déjà qu'est-ce que
c'est professeur casanier
bon c'est dans l'immense famille des
virus il y a quand même de des centaines
de milliers des millions de virus bien
sûr donc il y a des virus qui sont
pathogènes par l'homme dont multiple
familles parmi les familles où il y a
des pathogènes par l'homme il y a une
famille immense qui s'appelle les
sarbées covirus donc cette famille il y
a le sars la covid le sarce 2 mais il y
a aussi des quantités astronomiques de
virus qui sont pas pathogènes pour
l'homme qui vivent chez des animaux et
qui parfois sont pathogènes chez les
animaux ce constat est constaté sur tout
le Costa 2 ce qui a été écrit le Costa 2
ils ont il y a constat un costaud mais
le Costa on l'a pas on l'a pas tellement
vu parce que il a une caractéristique
c'est que lui tous ces virus utilisent
la même porte d'entrée pour envahir
notre organisme que le covid c'est le
AC2 d'accord
ils l'ont découvert en même temps on
évolue à une vitesse tellement
importante dans les virales que on voit
ça apparaître ils ont une
caractéristique comme toute cette
famille il passe par ce récepteur à ces
deux c'est quoi mais passer par le
récepteur à C2 ça nous suffit pas pour
dire que ça va déclencher une maladie
c'est quoi le C2 le récepteur AC2 on en
a beaucoup parlé au début de l'épidémie
c'est la porte d'entrée le virus arrive
et il arrive
on s'enclencher et pouvoir rentrer dans
notre organisme avec
le C2 c'est un récepteur que nous avons
tous qu'on partage avec beaucoup
d'autres espèces animales
dont les chauves-souris ah oui nous
sommes des animaux et on a des points
communs avec les chauves-souris c'est un
mammifère
la famille des chauves-souris regarde
malin
très moches qui ont un nez avec les
muqueuses vers l'extérieur et une
membrane qui fait comme un U et c'est un
nom spécial
rhinofilidé parce que ils ont un énorme
mené je sais pas ce que c'est pour mieux
avoir des le contrôle de l'écho et de
son sonar c'est énorme la nature elle
est belle donc
elles avaient plein de maladies mais
nous en avons tous plein de bactéries
sur nous les chauves-souris c'est
toujours ils sont tous les maladies
elles sont toujours en avant là mais les
chauves-souris elles ont cette
particularité c'est qu'elle partage avec
nous le fait d'être
un sujet qui peut héberger des
coronavirus les armées covirus et
certains virus on sait et avant de vous
dire si c'est pathogène sont pas pour ne
pas balader pour ne pas porter un peu le
contexte sachez que nous savons qu'il y
a probablement au moins 400 virus
parasites ou bactéries extrêmement
dangereux et qui représente un danger
potentiel donc c'est 400 il y a certains
éléments des sarrebrucks au virus qui
pourraient émerger comme un pathogène
comme la covid est émergée je ne veux
pas dire que nous sommes certains mais
nous sommes obligés de les surveiller ça
c'est émergence des nouveaux virus mais
il y a des dangers de Ré émergence des
maladies dont on s'en était débarrassés
je vous rappelle par exemple que le sud
de l'Europe était une zone où il avait
du valorisme maintenant avec le
changement climatique le Palu on se pose
la question si on va pas réimplanter le
paludisme il y a de la et il y a eu cet
été
[Rires]
autochtones de dingue donc vous voyez
qu'il a un risque de réémergence et que
le principal facteur déterminant de son
risque de réémergence il en a
probablement deux le premier c'est le
changement climatique c'est ça tu vois
voilà et le deuxième c'est un élément
aussi qu'il faut considérer comme
extrêmement important c'est la
modification de nos habitudes de vie les
hommes nous allons beaucoup plus dans
des endroits où avant on n'y allait pas
qui était par exemple les forêts
équatoriales où on peut récupérer des
virus et c'est pour aller chercher du
pétrole et aller chercher du bois
il y a un danger juste pour tout le
monde qui est la résistance aux
antibiotiques qui va me tuer des
millions de personnes dans les années à
venir il faut arrêter de prendre des
antibiotiques parce qu'on a mal à la
gorge il faut arrêter d'avaler des
antibiotiques comme si on est des
cachetons et des gâteaux ce n'est pas
possible il faut vraiment réagir à ça
donc aujourd'hui pour terminer nous
avons un risque d'émergence émergence de
risque infectieux nous devons être
extrêmement vigilants ces virus en
particulier le Costa et le Costa 2
aujourd'hui ne représentent pas un
danger pour nous le fait qu'il résiste à
la vaccination je me vaccine pas contre
toutes les bactéries qu'on croise au
quotidien il y a un danger potentiel
mais c'est aujourd'hui nous savons
qu'ils ont pas la mutation qui
permettraient qu'il déclenchent de
malades des maladies chez nous donc pour
le moment sauf si le virus mute demain
il me met une claque et il me dit que
les aliments arrête de dire
la probabilité qu'il mute d'aujourd'hui
à demain à l'époque probable il est se
ne représente pas un danger immédiat
mais il faut que vous imaginiez
l'intensité de la recherche scientifique
les modifications dans la recherche
scientifique on est en train de modifier
les noms de bactéries les noms des virus
la classification des virus parce que
nous avons une capacité technique à
beaucoup mieux comprendre et expliquer
comment on évolue et quels sont les
dangers
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un danger mais
soyons prudent et en conscience des
dangers qui sont à l'horizon j'insiste
nous devons lutter contre le changement
pour l'instant donc pas d'inquiétude
mais c'est ce qu'on nous disait aussi
sur le début
d'inquiétude pourquoi il y a un focus
tout d'un coup sur ce virus et pourquoi
tout les médias s'en emparent et
pourquoi celui-là
on connaît ces virus depuis pas mal de
temps et je je suis amusé tout à l'heure
quand j'ai eu votre journaliste à
regarder tous les articles qui avaient
été publiés depuis 2021 il y en a des
articles qui sont sortis la tout d'un
coup il en a un qui est sorti le 22
septembre et celui qui sortit le 22
septembre a été très marketing
c'est-à-dire il a eu un impact il a des
pertes des journalistes qui s'en sont
saisis et qui en ont parlé mais il n'a
rien apporté vraiment de nouveau on
savait c'est pas surprenant on sait que
ça passe par le AC2 on sait que ça passe
par le a.c² que le vaccin ne marche pas
bah écoutez c'est normal il n'a pas été
fait contre ça c'est comme sur Mova King
contre la covid et j'espère que ça me
protège de la rage c'est sûr c'est comme
si donc ce n'était pas le problème donc
pour le moment je dirais rassurons-nous
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
rester mobilisé et que nous devons avoir
une attitude adulte raisonnable et de
protection de notre environnement le
danger c'est que nous sommes en train de
détruire notre environnement
et qu'on nous donnait des lunettes
ce virus aussi comme le covid est lié au
changement climatique
et c'est intéressant disons que le
changement climatique va favoriser des
changements parce que nous allons dans
des endroits où on y allait pas le dégel
du permafrost est en train de faire
émerger des virus que avec lesquels on
n'avait pas des contacts et on arrive on
a identifié un certain nombre de virus
dont on connaît pas tellement le
potentiel pathogénique le changement
climatique modifie également un élément
majeur c'est que
majorité de ces risques émergents et
réémergents sont des sonoses c'est des
maladies chez les animaux et qui vont
venir chez l'homme les inondations les
sécheresses tous ces dangers risquent de
modifier notre environnement et faire
que ces maladies qui sont chez les
animaux soit en contact avec nous c'est
déjà arrivé avec des rats par exemple
voilà revenir alors les mêmes
les antavirus aussi une famille de virus
qui donne la maladie extrêmement grave
et lorsqu'il y a eu des inondations les
ras les populations Dora de mulots ont
extrêmement bougé je dis mulots c'est
pas exactement les mulots mais c'est des
variétés de rails de souris énormément
bougé en raison des inondations et ils
ont contaminé des populations qui
n'étaient pas habituées et ça met en
danger les populations et les animaux je
vous rappelle que ça impact économique
pourquoi il y a de plus en plus de râles
dans les villes avant il y a 20 ans
c'est ça aussi c'est dans toutes les
villes il y a entre 1 et 10 rares par
habit
[Musique]
je suis copain je connais bien madame
Hidalgo mais c'est pas pour la défense
mais il est venu à l'hôpital plusieurs
fois on a eu l'occasion discuter et
juste pour l'anecdote on parle en
espagnol quand on se voit non
très bien espagnol en Espagne alors hein
[Rires]
il y a beaucoup de travaux à Paris
et deuxième élément place de la Concorde
et deuxième élément il y a aussi un
problème d'hygiène on laisse traîner des
aliments les pourries
du coup il y a des rats qui viennent
donc on est plus seul à Paris il y a
probablement un rapport un habitant 75
professeurs
tu te réveilles en sursaut tu fais chier
tout le monde
grande ville dont des pays dont on voit
de développement
un dira pour un avis
il y a deux responsables pour moi
Hidalgo et les Anglais voilà
on va pas se raconter l'histoire des
films tout de même est-ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que à force nos
habitudes humaines d'avoir empiéter
comme ça sur la nature et sur les
animaux aujourd'hui on prend le coup de
bâton on prend le revers et aussi dire
que aujourd'hui tout ce qui se passe
c'est la conséquence de ben oui de
d'habitude donc ce serait bien peut-être
de chance oui non mais ce serait ce
serait intéressant que mondialement on
se transforme mais profondément parce
que sinon
profondément parce que sinon il sera
trop tard et et personne autour de cette
table et même dans le public personne ne
comprend qu'il faut totalement changer
nos habitudes et il faut tout revoir
sinon on va à notre perte et la fin du
monde c'est pour demain
par exemple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais alors oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe professeur est-ce que vous pensez
pas que tout ça non pas toi toi lui
là-bas non
c'est bon
tout ça il sort de guerre de
communication comme par hasard c'est
trouver en Russie bah ouais c'est ça ce
que vous pensez pas qu'on en parle parce
que justement on veut montrer on a
intimidé on veut on veut montrer que la
Russie forcément il y a peut-être un
danger justement d'en mettre les deux
blocs face à face
en Russie c'est plutôt une bonne chose
on pourrait rajouter à la liste noire
des Anglais de Madame Hidalgo les Russes
mais
dans le monde scientifique j'espère que
ce n'est pas le cas je pense qu'il y a
eu des travaux qui ont mis longtemps ils
ont été publiés et je vais vous dire
c'est variété de de chauve-souris existe
dans ce qu'on appelle l'ancien c'est à
dire l'Asie l'Europe une partie de
l'Afrique c'est des animaux ces
chauves-souris très très présents et qui
sont donc potentiellement porteurs de
ces virus on le sait mais il n'y a pas
que ses animaux il y a les chameaux par
exemple
on sait que par exemple avec la covid il
est beaucoup de cervidés ils sont
actuellement porteurs de ces virus donc
on sait que dans la nature beaucoup
d'animaux des mammifères les pangolins
etc sont porteurs de ces virus et qu'il
y a donc un réservoir animal qui
pourrait nous revenir donc nous devons
être en permanence
je dis dans le monde de scientifique que
ça vous concerne peut-être pas vous
direz comprend pas ce que vous dites
mais
[Applaudissements]
voilà
je te le dis là il était en cours en SVT
comprenait rien voilà et comme moi mais
on est très content tu nous as rassuré
c'est l'essentiel merci Cédric merci
d'avoir répondu